our next guest is the hilarious comedian
Fortune feemster she's been making
audiences laugh for more than a decade
with her appearances on Chelsea Lately
The Mindy Project and her two Netflix
comedy specials now she's starring
alongside Arnold Schwarzenegger I know
in the new Netflix spy Thriller series
it's called FUBAR it stands for Gail you
know now I know now I didn't know
yesterday effed up beyond all
recognition as we used to say in the
Army Teamster is helping to save the
world with Schwarzenegger in his first
TV series she plays a CIA field
operative named Roo whose analytics also
help her colleagues personal lives
here's a preview
I just airdropped you Recon on Tina
online purchases Spotify playlist
Netflix history it turns out she has a
Nostalgia erection for the 70s sucks for
you because men back then were men Steve
McQueen oh Newman and you ain't them I
don't know we grab late night tacos the
other day and she just complimented my
muscles it's because we're undercover
you think she's really interested in
your linguine arms
[Music]
origin theme sir joins us now welcome to
the show oh thank you guys for having us
we're so happy you're here the movie's
hilarious
um we were all saying what was it like
when you were first approached for the
series and they offered you an action
action role look at you action star I
mean I clearly you know the Rock and I
are twins
um so it wasn't too much of a shock but
no I really never thought I would get
the opportunity to do something like
this so as soon as it was offered I was
like absolutely you know to do an action
series with one of the biggest action
stars in the world I mean that's
incredible did he have any advice for
you in getting prepared doing the stunts
uh he was the fortune when you shoot a
gun don't blink
okay
don't blink
you can't help it but imitate him I mean
too when you're around him yeah every
time I'm around him I'm like come on
Arnold get to the chopper let's go
but you know he has a great sense of
humor so what's so great about this role
I think for you which by the way guys
was number one on Netflix yeah for four
days it's trending also Global worldwide
really that's another feather in your
cap thank you but you have you have some
of the funniest lines in the movie I
have to say that I thought a lot of them
were ad-lib because you do that so
effortlessly effortlessly but we got to
see you being vulnerable we got to see
being set what was that like to show
that side of your acting abilities it
was different yeah I really enjoyed that
opportunity because a lot of people know
me from my stand-up they know me for my
silly characters yeah
um and you know acting is something I
really love I've I've been on some
really cool shows but to get to go there
and show emotion and and not be you know
just the joke person was you nervous
about taking that on oh for sure that
day I was you know pacing around trying
to you know just really get in my head
space of of that what that moment would
be like and you know try to work on the
lip quiver oh
it's not as good in the morning but uh
it was no it was I really took that
responsibility seriously yeah uh you're
very funny in your stand up oh you've
got a half hour of Comedy Central uh
recently and you're touring now you're
from the South but you're now touring
through the South as well and I feel
like it's a tough time for comedians
because different audiences have
different tolerances for jokes yeah and
for the types of people they meet these
days has the South changed to you since
you grew up there I mean you know I I
it's been a while since I've lived there
but I am Southern I grew up in North
Carolina
um so it's it's a world that I'm
familiar with and a place that I don't
shy away from you know it's where I I
grew up and I have a lot of great
memories there but a lot of my stand-up
is storytelling I stick to my stories I
talk a lot about my family I talk a lot
about my relationship I don't really get
into politics and whatnot there are
people who do it way better than me um
so I'm just trying to tell stories that
everyone can relate but it's relatable
yeah but I look at your life though here
you are I go back to Fortune 2 2003 you
come to I think California yeah so
you're in you have thirty dollars to
your name what were you gonna do with
the thirty dollars number one and you're
driving an Acura an Acura Legend what
were you thinking as you go there and
then fast forward to 2023 and here you
are with Arnold I mean it's wild I think
when you're that age you're not really
thinking uh like that this is a huge
thing and you're very naive in that like
I mean let's just see what happens what
was your plan with thirty dollars in
your low car I mean man I think I just I
had an opportunity to work as a as a
personal assistant at some point and and
I think I was just like let's just
usually have a life experience yeah and
you're doing better now if I needed to
borrow 30 I mean you
full circle moment the show premiered 20
years to the week of when I moved to LA
and I had you know thirty dollars to my
name and to have this kind of show come
out and show the hard work that it took
to get there it's not an overnight thing
it really does take Jack's like being
part of your act you said you talk about
your relationships yes
she she's a great sport about it she's
like okay you don't need to include this
dear yeah right there's some things to
be kept to us but we'll go on a hike and
she'll she'll be the one that's like oh
remember that you know story about when
we got a got in a fight on the the train
in Europe you know we'll talk about that
so she's really good about but you you
talk about her and you yeah you know
this is pride month uh you came out gay
later in life and you're still touring
in these conservative cities yeah what's
the reaction like when you do talk this
is what I was trying to get it yeah
I mean
I need representation right I came out
later in life because I didn't see
myself represented in any stories I had
no thing that I could relate to so I
take the responsibility very seriously I
go into these places where people are
starved to to hear stories like mine
they want to see themselves in my story
and if you know they're either part of
the community or an ally you can look
around and see there's a room full of
2000 people who are are leading with
love acceptance and I think that's an
important thing and the best part is
they get to laugh and I love that I get
to do that did you know what Fubar meant
I did I did
all right Fortune it's so great to have
you congratulations one last Arnold
impression before we go uh it's not a
tumor it's the best one ubar is
currently streaming on Netflix okay